[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24 en
medio de la cuenta regresiva para la
toma de posesión del nuevo presidente de
eeuu se mantiene la extrema seguridad en
la ciudad de washington el mandatario
electo joe biden dio un emotivo mensaje
antes de partir hacia la capital federal
mientras que el presidente saliente
donald trump se despidió a través de un
mensaje en youtube
fuertemente custodiadas sin público en
medio de tensión y sin la presencia del
presidente saliente la ceremonia de toma
de posesión del presidente electo joe
biden será histórica por el contexto
político y social de eeuu aún así hay
expectativa por el discurso y el mensaje
que va a tentar a a sus ciudadanos y al
mundo entero
500 agentes de la policía y del ejército
de guatemala dispersaron la caravana de
unos 6 mil ciudadanos hondureños que
intentaban continuar su camino hacia
eeuu los enfrentamientos no dejaron
heridos de gravedad pero provocó que
miles de ellos regresaran a su país de
origen
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález estamos en vivo desde nuestros
estudios en bogotá en colombia vamos a
comenzar en la capital de eeuu en la
ciudad de washington en donde allí
ultiman los detalles y también avanza ya
la cuenta regresiva para la ceremonia de
toma de posesión del presidente electo
de eeuu joe biden y de su vicepresidenta
kamala harris
washington la capital es y ya
fuertemente custodiada por 25 mil
integrantes de la guardia nacional el
centro de la ciudad se ha convertido en
una zona fortificada con cierres de
calles las estaciones de metro algunas
de ellas también fueron cerradas
controles militares y bloques de cemento
de otra parte el presidente electo joe
biden dio unas emotivas declaraciones al
momento de su partida hacia la ciudad de
washington a su turno el presidente
saliente de donald trump también destacó
varios logros de su mandato a través de
un mensaje en youtube por el cual
también se despidió
y hace 12 años estaba esperando en la
estación de tren de wilmington a que un
hombre negro me recogiera de camino a
washington donde juramos como presidente
y vicepresidente de los eeuu de américa
y aquí estamos hoy mi familia y yo a
punto de regresar a washington para
encontrarnos con una mujer negra de
ascendencia del sur de asia y juntos
tomar posesión como presidente y
vicepresidenta de los eeuu
los estadounidenses estábamos
aterrorizados por el asalto a nuestro
capitolio la violencia política es un
ataque en todo lo que celebramos como
estadounidenses y nunca será tolerado
ahora más que nunca debemos unirnos en
nuestros valores compartidos y
levantarnos del partidismo y alcanzar
nuestro destino
vamos a analizar este tema saludamos a
césar paz ex agente o agente retirado
del fbi y también consultor en seguridad
muy buenas noches señora paz ante el
aumento de la violencia que vemos allí
en eeuu el aumento de los grupos de
extrema derecha y la fuerte división
que tiene la sociedad de estados unidos
y este panorama que vemos en el país
completamente militarizado es esta la
nueva normalidad de esta transición de
poder en eeuu
buenas noches antes gracias por la
invitación en primer lugar el aumento
del nivel de seguridad tan alto que se
ha visto nuestra mente en el capítulo iv
para control de estados es algo
abrumador es algo que no sé no lo hemos
visto anteriormente pero está lista de
más que las agencias de inteligencia han
recibido información y han detectado que
es posible que existan o que ocurran
mañana
ciertos actos de violencia en contra no
solamente de los que van a asistir entre
los integrantes de este cambio de mando
pero también quieren resguardar la de
los edificios federales en washington
dicen que están en cada esquina señor
paz hablamos de 25 mil soldados que
están custodiando la ciudad de
washington esto no tiene precedentes en
la historia de eeuu se puede confiar en
que la ceremonia de mañana tendrá lugar
sin problemas
denos un parte de tranquilidad
bueno en primer lugar no es la primera
vez que ocurre un evento como este sin
embargo es la primera vez en la historia
que hay una concurrencia militar tan
alta una presencia militar tan alta
personas no van a existir esto va a ser
algo básicamente
ceremonial expresado ceremonial no
presencial pero al mismo tiempo
recordemos que eeuu tiene enemigos que
no solamente son domésticos pero tener
son foráneos y la información que he
recibido ha hecho que el fbi ponga o
ejecuten ciertos planes de seguridad en
a través de todos los estados unidos y
cada uno de los eeuu donde existe una
oficina de celis hay un puesto de
comando y están operando desde tempranas
horas de la mañana hasta altas horas de
la noche y monitoreando todo lo que está
sucediendo alrededor no solamente de
washington en eeuu y también en el
exterior señor paz muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros en france 24 está
parte de tranquilidad sobre la situación
que se está viviendo allí de cara a esta
ceremonia de toma de posesión del
presidente electo de eeuu joe biden que
ocurre con un país militarizado como ya
lo decíamos con soldados custodiando el
capitolio y con un clamor para una
jornada pacífica la ceremonia genera
mucha expectativa por el discurso que
dará el presidente electo cuál va a ser
su mensaje a los
todo ante un hecho sin precedentes y es
la ausencia del mandatario saliente
donald trump que afirmó que no asistiría
a esta ceremonia en rechazo al
reconocimiento al triunfo de bailén en
las urnas
son muchas las posibles fuentes de
inspiración para bailar en 1937 frank
roosevelt iniciaba su segundo mandato
con un icónico mis queridos compatriotas
no parece que bailen vaya a imitar el
estilo de harry truman quien invitó al
periodista court en morning que había
pronosticado su derrota
en un box agente de papel apropiado
mucho más sobria fue la toma de posesión
de su sucesor en 1953
una jura habitual que repitieron
también lyndon johnson
en 1973 richard nixon lanzó un mensaje
que caducaría muy pronto
pesos yo mandé a ellos en el caso de
gerald ford decidió jugar con la primera
dama a su lado jimmy carter optó por un
discurso de nuevos tiempos que bien
podría inspirar al aire
en el hall
nacionales el demócrata dejó el mando a
ronald reagan quien reivindicó la
transición de presidente un mensaje que
hoy bien valdría para donald trump veces
es salaam en muchos momentos se case
con george bush padre en su inauguración
ya hablaba de la unidad de los
estadounidenses
[Aplausos]
y más poético fue bill clinton en 1993
we force spinning mensajes para la
historia en una jornada de gran
expectación como demuestran las masivas
posesiones de los últimos presidentes
george bush y barack obama puso muy
fuerte y la del presidente saliente de
donald trump software cambiamos de tema
el gobierno de guatemala dispersó la
caravana de seis mil migrantes que
partió desde honduras hacia eeuu unos
500 agentes de la policía nacional civil
de guatemala e integrantes del ejército
desalojaron la carretera donde los
migrantes estaban parados a la espera de
poder retomar su marcha rumbo a la
frontera con méxico en el norte del país
los enfrentamientos no dejaron hasta el
momento heridos de gravedad e hizo
retroceder a los migrantes que queda
dispersados en esta zona muchos optaron
por regresar a honduras otros buscan
rutas alternativas para llegar a eeuu
un forzado paso atrás la población de
valhondo al sur de guatemala se
convirtió en un punto muerto para la
caravana de migrantes que partió desde
honduras el viernes buscando llegar a
eeuu
con presencia de la policía militar la
caravana fue dispersada para reabrir el
tránsito de la carretera y bloquear el
paso de unas 4000 personas que
permanecían en total de unas ocho mil
que se estima comenzaron el viaje el fin
de semana y ellos han maltratado la casa
de perra mediante para tu país no es
mucho esto
valhondo se encuentra a sólo 55
kilómetros de la frontera sur con
honduras es todavía el comienzo de un
largo viaje que ella en guatemala se
enfrenta a la oposición del gobierno
evitar que continúen en su trayectoria
para llegar a la frontera mexicana donde
no se les dejara pasar y donde se podrá
sí sí si no lo evitamos podemos tener
una potencial crisis humanitaria de gran
escala méxico ya ha desplegado a su
guardia nacional en chiapas su frontera
con guatemala su presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador le recordó a su
homólogo electo de estados unidos joe
biden su promesa de campaña de realizar
una reforma migratoria según la agencia
ap ese plan incluiría un plazo de ocho
años para
y regularizar a los 11 millones de
personas que viven en la unión americana
sin definir su estatus migratorio
en otros temas en china un panel
independiente que revisa el manejo
global de la pandemia de kobe 19 indicó
que los funcionarios de ese país
asiático podrían haber aplicado medidas
más firmes contra la pandemia de kobe 19
el panel también criticó la forma como
la ms declaró esta emergencia
internacional lo hizo hasta el 30 de
enero del 2020 podría haber sido antes
así lo dijo este panel además agregó que
la oms no ha tenido suficiente fuerza
para hacer el trabajo que le corresponde
y pidió un reinicio global al tiempo que
indicó que dará recomendaciones
generales a los ministros de salud
alrededor del mundo
y colombia registró 15 mil 939 nuevos
casos de contagio de kobe 19 en sólo 24
horas las cifras las dio a conocer el
ministerio de salud y de protección
social que también reportó la muerte de
398 personas a causa del coronavirus
colombia se ha acercado rápidamente a
los 2 millones de casos de contagio al
contabilizar al día de hoy un millón
novecientos treinta y nueve mil casos de
contagio
y en francia aumenta la presión en las
unidades de cuidado intensivo de los
hospitales de ese país europeo los
contagios siguen en aumento rápidamente
y los expertos temen el surgimiento de
una nueva variante o la llegada de una
de las agresivas variantes existentes
esto mientras el personal de salud se
mantiene firme en su lucha contra el
kobe 19 veamos
las mascarillas caseras hechas de tela
ya no serían una barrera suficiente
contra el coronavirus el ministro de
salud francés origen dijo recomienda a
partir de ahora el uso de máscaras de
grado industrial pues éstas pueden
filtrar el aire al menos en un 90% esto
como medida preventiva ante una nueva
variante del virus que ya preocupa en el
país
para algunos el argumento no convence si
mantenemos el distanciamiento social en
general con otras personas francamente
no creo que las mascarillas quirúrgicas
sean totalmente necesarias pero en los
hospitales la situación se hace cada vez
más crítica una nueva oleada de
contagios obligó al gobierno a endurecer
nuevamente las restricciones pero los
pacientes siguen llegando y los
trabajadores de la salud temen que lo
peor puede estar por venir
pero no juegas tú
no estamos un poco ansiosos de que en un
par de semanas tal vez las cifras suban
ya que eso es lo que los institutos de
salud están pronosticando así que
estamos contando mucho con las vacunas
pero entonces esta enfermedad nos ha
enseñado que a veces tenemos que dejar
de hacer pronósticos y tratar de
mantener lo que sabemos y adaptarnos a
los acontecimientos
las autoridades no descartan la
posibilidad de un tercer confinamiento
nos de poco fin hemos puesto a nuestro
país en dos cierres y en ambas ocasiones
porque lo hicimos porque los hospitales
estaban saturados todas las proyecciones
mostraban que estábamos teniendo cifras
de infección que podrían estar llegando
a 50 mil casos diarios ahora es otro
cierre una medida que tomaremos en
cualquier caso no puedo decírselo con
seguridad en cualquier caso lo que puedo
decirles es que la propagación del virus
sigue siendo preocupante dentro del país
en medio de los temores que desata la
variante británica del virus francia ha
visto como la cantidad de personas en
uso ha superado las 2800 por primera vez
en un mes las vacunas apenas han llegado
a cerca de 500 mil personas
en italia el primer ministro de ese país
joseph e conté obtuvo la confianza del
senado italiano pese a esto el primer
italiano perdió la mayoría absoluta algo
que compromete su margen de
gobernabilidad conte perdió el apoyo de
18 senadores de italia viva la formación
del ex primer ministro matteo renzi por
las diferencias en el presupuesto para
las ayudas por la pandemia del cob y 19
es todo por el momento en la noticia de
france 24 buenas noches
[Música]